in this problem a given 8T deep primary
clarifier has an average overflow rate
of 500 Gall per square foot day and a
peak overflow rate of 1,000
Gall per square foot day the average
flow entering the plant is 0.8 MGD and
the peaking factor is two during Peak
flow conditions what is the hydraulic
retention time of the flow in
hours so the first thing we need to do
is search the reference manual for
hydraulic residence this will take us to
page
444 of version 2.0 of the reference
manual this page contains both equations
we will need for this
problem so the problem is asking us to
find the hydraulic retention time the
equation for hydraulic retention time is
as follows the hydraulic retention
tension time or theta equals the volume
over the
flow we can find flow in the problem but
we are still missing the volume of the
clarifier this brings us to our second
equation which is right above the first
equation the Overflow rates described in
the problem can also be called the
hydraulic loading rate and can be seen
to have the same unit of gallons over
days * fet
squared this equation contains a term
for
area so if we solve this equation first
we can next solve the equation we have
for our hydraulic retention time so
let's do
it the problem wants us to solve during
Peak flow conditions so for now we need
to multiply the average Flow by the
peaking
Factor
we would then divide this by the
Overflow rate also known as the
hydraulic loading rate for the peak flow
condition as
well and the hydraulic loading rate
we're going to pick is going to be the
peak flow overflow
rate giving our answer to be
1600 square
feet so this gives us the square feet
but we need the volume given that the
problem gives us a depth the volume can
be calculated very
quickly now we can set up our original
equation so Theta equals
volume over
[Music]
flow we know that
our volume is going to
be
12,800 cubic
feet and our flow is going to
be 1.6 million gallons or
1, 600
gallons per day so we will notice that
we will require one more unit conversion
here from gallons to cubic
feet you can either have this memorized
or you can find this unit conversion in
the beginning of the reference manual
and it's going to
be 1 cubic foot is equal to
7.48
gallons
simplifying this
down we get 2
904 on the
bottom and those units are now cubic
feet per
day and the problem is asking us for the
hydraulic retention time in hours so
it's important to
note that our first simplification here
is going to be
days so we have one more unit conversion
to
do 24
hours in one
day that's going to give us just about
1.44 hours which we can see is our third
answer over
here so this problem can be solved very
quickly if we know what to search for in
the reference manual such as hydraulic
retention leading us to our two
equations on page
444 or even if we can simply see what we
need from the units that the problem
provides make sure to multiply by your
peaking
factor and make sure to use the correct
overflow or hydraulic loading rate and
you should be able to solve this problem
fairly quickly and that's
it